most threes and a half seven by russell
westbrook
and by kawhi leonard here's number seven
anything you can do i can do better mr
lillard
and here's curry firing away
with 20 seconds to go in the half
oh my god you see what you started
reggie
what i started he
that was goaltending on that follow-up
three seconds to go curry from deep
knocks it down with a second to go
there you go holiday from half court
keeping golden state in the game chris
middleton is the leading scorer for
milwaukee he's the biggest reason
the bucks lead curry and the warriors by
10. that should be a new rule when
you're up this much you got to end it on
a three if you need three
all right what's lilo thinking about
here
[Applause]
that's what he's thinking about game
time
game time baby in all four quarters but
by winning
the fourth it's 300
000 for thurgood marshall college fund
and they have done very well
with 150 000 for the first second and
third quarter and then 300 more
here in the fourth one they started in
the middle he flashed the middle and he
just backed up and no one went with him
and he's like oh no one's here i'm gonna
shoot oh my goodness
hurry with a three shot the clock is
running down
he doesn't miss a whole lot of those
dame created the opportunity for robert
the last possession let's see if he
creates with somebody else or just calls
his own number i like his phone better
damian lillard yeah the time before he
saw the help coming he got rid of the
basketball
allowed robert to drive this time he
just said three
and steph just steph is running into the
front court
draymond finds him another three
62 62.
and he actually surpasses his buddy clay
thompson
they're looking forward to draymond
green of course his boy
where's he at where's he at hand off
that is a tough shot too gary trent
right at him
of the screen roko saves it to little
[Applause]
dame deep dish serves it up to the bulls
and one [ __ ] one from well outside
the city limits
blazers push the lead to 17.
[Music]
he's not left-handed but he's almost
ambidextrous when it comes to his
finishing
and curry's got 18 now as he hits the
three
they just left him they just fell asleep
chicago with their highest scoring
quarter of the game here in the fourth
quarter so far
dang gets it with white checking dame
deep look from outside there's the three
similar situation in that same corner
dame is looking for the best three
possible for him it's out near half
court
logged in driving and looney did just
enough
[Applause]
and then just handles holiday
couldn't do anything about it from
potentially picking up their fifth
consecutive win
trying to close it out against the
thunder damien lillard why not
why not this is an mvp performance
from the hands of the thunder well it's
why he always feels like he has a chance
if he can be out there on the floor
he he truly believes he can win no
matter what the odds
may be no matter what it might look like
no matter who's in or out of the lineup
he believes he can accomplish things
other people
can't and it's it's easy to see why
after performances like this one fake
and drive by paul millsap with 12.
he leads denvering scoring three
what a shot by curry oh my goodness oh
look at that
35-footer ball even in his hand right
here
uh look there's just no work i mean
and easily could have been a four-point
play right i mean you gotta allow the
you gotta allow
the shooter to come down right try to
get something going here
two seconds left lillard from the logo
it's good
logo lillard
[Applause]
order for damien lillard
and one more look off the triggers
[Applause]
no need to be in a rush when you can
pull up from
40 blazers up by three
curry way downtown bang steph curry from
just inside half court
unbelievable that's his ninth
three-pointer of the game already
great to be back with you here on
tuesday night the nba on tnt
10185 pelicans oh my goodness take me
and lillard
unlimited range
well just look how deep this is i mean
there's really
second chance points too we'll be
watching that shot clock is off
steph down to two stops he backs all the
way up oh
no yo that is almost
unfair the game has been broken
and the lead has ballooned to 12 with a
minute to go in the third what i liked
about what portland has done though
oh wow willard a bomb
and then this time 34 feet
the the quickness of the release
difference between the shot clock and
game clock curry
working against none lets the three go
scores it steph with a huge dagger
point shooting night mark five foot 23
from the field the question is how many
shots did he miss
when it matters most the answer none
steph curry over kendrick nunn for the
knock down
dagger shot mama here goes that man
frank vogel he was questionable coming
into this game he had
some foot issues act up on him prior to
the game
does it he might lead the league and
fall down so look at damian lillard okay
look at where he makes it from and then
he just turns around no reaction
lebron on the move
picks up on a switch by buchanan
[Applause]
not fair please it's not fair
greg you're such a big reason why this
game has changed
but it's changed about 10 feet up from
you allow for morris to grab it cleanly
my goodness lillard
steph curry back in there
curry tries to backtrack
and fires from near south again
come on man see the whole sequence look
at this is good defense okay press the
ball he loses it look he laughs
he laughs and then just says okay
that is denver slow this guy down
lillard
launches wow
damian lindlard taking denver's heart
he's got 55 points look to attack but
lillard here i'm going to give him the
benefit of the doubt and said he called
glass spring goes to the basket gives it
up uber a for three
ubrae in and out and look at wiggins the
effort to run it down curry
three-pointer for stephen curry
bone injured comes right back
wiggins kept it alive curry
and steph dribbled it off his foot shot
clock at three
and curry gonna try to get one up from
way
deep and laser it in of course we've won
stephen curry behind the back buddy
yields all over him thought he was close
enough
you are not come on just rejected the
screen you want to force him to it
the help's on the other side you let him
go the other way it's going to be easier
for him oh man curry two for one
and he drops in at three yo the
unlimited range is
bamboozling everyone warriors have won
seven of ten
can they make it eighth of 11 with steph
shooting like that perhaps
curry deep three got it with an
opportunity for a four-point play
from minnetonka this often angela
russell
he's seen him do it a million times even
played with the guy
and he's still shocked that he shot it
from this far out he's just got
unlimited reign mulder will push find
curry again
and basically is saying wait oh he
backed up on him
and hit another three baseley fell
asleep
he thought he did his job curry for the
lead
rattled it out looney will track it down
steph one more time for the advantage
good
if at first you don't succeed you know
what they say
try try again nobody it should have been
gobert
but you got so much space look where go
bear is
he's the only one that's supposed to be
guarding this screen now kavon looney
has double digit rebounds in three
straight games he had never done that in
his career
nine point lead and you sense curry and
the warriors moving in for a little bit
of a kill here
steph in his bag deep
like the fries were at the bottom
the memphis grizzlies and it's what's
remarkable to me is how little he needs
the basketball to be successful
it's a pretty team to watch with the
constant movement and the passing